but i'm a lot older than you and i'm
trying to change that mindset i'm at the
point now where yeah i'm
almost dead
so that
no no
true what well how much how long is the
what's the oldest comic who is the
oldest comic
louis what
who louis who
louis how old is louis louis louie
anderson yeah i'm talking about dead
people who
who who died at the end
what's the longest little
he didn't make it to hunter
and asner was kind of a comment no he's
not he was on a comedy show he's not a
stand-up comic but here's the thing okay
i'm i'll be 66 that's great
well yeah yeah yeah yeah but but how
many years do i have left another 20.
so that's it so i have 20. i've been
doing it for 40. so i have a half as
much time left yeah than i already had
and here's what my my point being is you
realize at this point
it's okay
[Laughter]
all right okay but what i'm saying is
that you gotta at a certain point in
life you gotta go [ __ ] everybody else
and believe in yourself
oh god again more wisdom because it
doesn't matter because even if you're
great
it doesn't matter you know people in our
business always say how do you want to
be remembered you won't
i know right you won't you're right you
won't no matter how big i was just
reading about this guy the other day do
you know rory calhoun don't know him
don't know that name right yeah yeah
he has two stars on the walk of fame
in his day wow he was the number one
western star you know when westerns were
marvel yeah yeah of today you know
whoever was marvel whoever was that rory
calhoun was that the point i'm not
knocking rory calhoun yeah but i'm
saying two generations which is really
just almost 40 years the longest i've
been in the business yeah no matter what
you do nobody's going to remember so
enjoy this
imagine 100 years from now
walk of fame right some kid is going to
walk by and go who the [ __ ] was robert
downey jr well i have a star on the walk
of fame
oh you do yeah it was just this is a
long-winded way of telling you
nice
i want to look i wanted to see your
star where is it at the cross streets
well mine's on sepulveda
but it's still a star
and i drew it myself oh you did oh yeah
okay it is there but where is mine i
don't know yeah yeah find out where it
is find out where my star is you never
you don't i thought if i had a star i
would walk by it once a month i thought
so you thought so i did that the first
month all right and
well i was standing there and a lot of
people the most the biggest reaction i
got was could you move we're trying to
go in here right right right right right
did it say where it is no yeah does it
say i have one maybe i'm just fooling
myself
by the way george carlin was 71 when he
passed away
so that's a happy note
so five years
five years i got five years five years
thank you what about um um
okay stiller's dad
jerry stiller how old was he
ah
[Laughter]
this is taking a turn
i'm 66 do the math it's a lot that's
over 20 years yeah yeah two decades but
but okay but i've been around for 45 so
it's less than half all i'm saying is
that my
things have changed perspective you know
i used to think that if i got on the
tonight show that was the end-all and
be-all yeah and i did it tonight a bunch
of times but it wasn't it's never what
you think it is the end-all and be-all
was the one thing i said no to was the
one thing that in my psyche was the
biggest [ __ ] mistake somebody could
make the point is you don't know you
don't know you know that bad baby you
know she is
yeah okay she became famous she was uh
uh uh
a patient on dr phil yeah who goes check
me outside
is catch me outside cash me outside yeah
nobody went on that show if not if most
people would think i'm going on to be
humiliated by my mother yeah that
launched your [ __ ] rap career wow who
would think that so you don't know you
have you make this plan but you control
so literally you believe then do you
believe that like sometimes you found
her yes so i believe but i believe
everything if i look back sometimes i
believe everything kind of happens in
the right time yeah in place and i
believe that it feels almost like it's
planned
not by me
you know and i've told you this before
my theory in life
is yes
you just say yes as much as you can
you just say yes because and this sounds
kind of stupid but
no first of all there's a million more
reasons to say no if you think about it
but you shouldn't be thinking about it
because you could think this could
happen this happened last time this is
going to be bad but no is n-o which are
the first two letters of the word
nothing
nothing comes from no wow it does but if
you say yes
worst case scenario you fail and you've
gained some knowledge on what you
shouldn't do the next time you try
something similar yeah so just say yes
to ever you don't know
what comes out of any moment in your
life and if you're gonna shut a door
opportunity is there for everyone
but so many people don't step through
that door they just don't they have this
fear and and their fear is
how other people view them and that's
what they get their sense of themselves
based on what you think other people
think
[Music]